what are your guilty pleasures what are
you oh I like true crime shows I like
the IV Channel
I love I've talked about this III
there's a show called snapped
does anybody know snaps on oxygen okay
snap is rad it's about it's women who
kill their husbands usually and I love
it because there's always a part in
every show where the narrator goes and
that's when she snaps there's two
snapped moments that everyone is it
opens this is not funny
it's terrible people were murdered but
it's hilarious yeah and there's one
where it's a woman a guy as a 9-1-1 call
and I went what's the emergency and guy
goes ya know you know my wife she she
took a shot at me and but I got the gun
away from her and and you know I'm okay
we're all okay over here you know when
they go oh well do you have another gun
in the house and he goes um no I don't
think oh yeah we do yeah we do line goes
dead she shot him probably but if you
had to have a last moment on earth it
was comedy gold
yeah dude and then there's another guy
it's a super regional that show like
every like if it's like a it's like a
episode takes place in Chicago everybody
has the thickest Chicago accent
everyone's like yeah my dad was a cap
and my mom was a cap Rutter was a cap
father mother grandmother but at but
there's this guy and I forget was but
his little guy his wife was cheating on
him and she was moonlighting as a
stripper someplace and the guy goes his
wife she worked at a club called
knackers said it like am I allowed to
say this on television
can I see nagger and I say Macker okay
get your bleep out cuz get the bleep
button get it ready cuz I'm about to
blow your minds here we come FCC
knackers crew trying true crime shows I
don't know if you guys have noticed this
but they always they always have to have
the narrative that they had it seemed
like they had the perfect marriage yes
even when it's clear they don't yes
yeah and so they're always saying they
had it all they lived in a very small
trailer home
[Applause]
was one of the larger trailer homes and
then you're like yeah nobody I mean they
had tried to divorce only twice and he
was about to find work again it was
perfect but then it all started to go
like no they didn't speak the same
language and they lived in a one-room
trailer house that was it was perfect it
was in the bottom of a dump
yeah and they always just have the one
picture - yeah it's just the one picture
watch any true crime show it's always
like and it's an embarrassing picture of
some guy like she loved Troy Troy was
the looker and I'm like you know Troy's
in prison or dead or whatever going come
on I got more pictures of me the neck I
love snapped so much all right let's get
the word out I love that you're not even
you're here to promote another show
HBO's like it feels like we don't do
snap dumbass